hey
thanks for coming can we sign off on
this he wants veto right over any roy
family member ever taking over as ceo
what's so great about this episode is
that it's all on borrowed time all that
deal making it should have happened two
weeks ago do you mind if we take a beat
yeah you have tons of time and it's like
yes anything that makes the deal
worthless please just sign here and
we'll work everything out later there's
nothing to discuss
right but it's basically
optics i don't think jerry's plotting
against them they don't seem to have the
job anyway everyone but them seem to
know what [ __ ] ups they are with all due
respect jerry yep and and then she picks
up on romans being sort of hurt by that
sorry about oh about what trying to [ __ ]
me over to consolidate your position and
i think she does try to walk it back a
little bit
hey pie got a minute later connor he has
some leverage and so often in his life
in that family he hasn't had any
leverage i wanted to ask you for a
really significant role to burnish my
reputation i've seen from watching my
brothers and sisters the only way to get
ahead in this family and this company is
to play dirty you were never interested
i don't do ancient history i don't want
to get into ancient history either so if
i have some [ __ ] on what he did with my
mother yeah i might call a press
conference logan's weak i need a purse
you want to make a decision now before
so the kids have to choose whether to
use that moment of weakness to further
their own positions
okay i think we go back to sandy and
stewie and try and save the deal no no
you can't because dad said no dad didn't
say [ __ ]
no he didn't his urethra had rested
control from his brain shiv knows that
she can get this across the line in this
moment hey
uh
if we can have another chat just the two
of us before the vote closes shiv has
that choice and she makes her move
what's going on how about a fourth seat
on the board
for you and there's a positioning
element to her that will maximize her
personal benefit in whatever scenario
she's in and way star for balance will
need an extra one
for me
i see
i've got the white house on the line
it's the president like all the good
things in the show this came out of a
debate discussion about who would take
that call i mean if anyone here is
bootleg logan roman jerry does think
that might be disarming for roman to get
on the phone are you kidding are you
sure i think there's also part of jerry
it's like hugo but that's not to
endanger roman that's just a gut
instinct of saving your own hide at any
cost
uh
how are you doing there has been a good
amount of evolution for roman in terms
of uh at the beginning i don't think he
really understood what his job was but
he thought fake it till you make it i
think that you are a
really significant historical figure and
right now he's feeling confident and
it's a little bit odd like is this it is
this all my job is i can do this
i think i'm doing it i can even talk to
the president i'm pretty good
congratulations you did it
i need to see all the detail the biggest
disappointment i think is with shiv we
couldn't risk a vote she is ostensibly
his favorite and she's constantly trying
to prove something for all these kids
it's easy to be their father's emissary
and he has a double-edged attitude to
their independence what would you have
done then not that he just doesn't like
not being the center of attention
exactly he doesn't not like being the
one who made it happen what would you
have done i'd have figured it out they
are his children and he wants them to
succeed but he doesn't want to say this
is the lesson you should be doing this
he wants them to find out stop buzzing
in my [ __ ] ear he's certainly a
disciplinarian but he's not always a
great instructor your dad wants a word
yeah let's go okay these people have
grown up in a way that has inflicted
damage on them you could say if it
wasn't for my dad i would have been this
i understand that but it's an excuse you
have to own who you are we are abused
and hurt people hurt people
block this number for me you sure
permanently
you